animate I didn't I didn't buy much in
this store it was the first fight I want
to pull the trigger okay so here's the
here's the thing about animates I didn't
know how much I should wash revealing
right now what do we do I mean who wants
to go first
I mean okay oh can I kill the host again
I'll go first because I only bought one
thing at a time okay so one of my
challenges was to get a maid in abyss
figurine yeah couldn't find it not even
not just an animate any of the storm but
I figured you know what I'll get
something like kind of cool and kind of
niche so I got Chucky mother from Dora
oh yeah it's a nindroid of Chucky mother
and I mean what was so [ __ ] yeah
I love me my physical samus stuff and I
love dodo and I was like you know I like
when androids two really really cute I
mean we will probably figure out the
pose of it somehow but yeah that's the
special thing about nan droids you just
have to you got to pick one pose and
that's it's never good we all know it's
never good also see Nikki as well but
once you've like nailed it you'll like
hell exactly yeah so that's the only
thing I got cuz yeah I got a few things
I don't know um so it's I had to
challenge us right I think I got [ __ ]
over over some of the overarching
challenges bye bye just animates itself
really okay let's let's go ahead so the
first thing for the first challenge was
to buy a Deku figure from my ear a
khadeem oh yeah so yeah as we all know
one of the overarching challenges was
the word the person who buys a figure
from the most popular series getting to
duck to the point yeah yeah so there's
there's my deck I was actually getting
bit worried right because there weren't
many like figures really varied yes so
the only thing I could find on
Nendoroids
and so my second challenge was to ask a
store clerk yeah what is Japanese
I recommend me okay what have you
recommend you okay he recommended to me
Edward Elric
I was like oh my god you've won he
recommends me the figure from the one
series until you've just made me also
lose a point by recommending to me a
check I checked for the fourth most
popular anime series on Mouse cuz you
should I see the price there that's
that's 48 bucks right yeah how much I
spend on these two this one says 48 88
and yes one says that was like about 550
- but this one will be a little bit more
expand he's got done dirty by that man
yeah I was like I in the videos like oh
thank you very much for recommending
that's not I'm just like oh I can't
believe you've done this which cracks me
up
yeah which is an Ishtar plushie it's
faster it's like it's like a giant
Simpson yeah uh $120 Jesus I only spend
versus thirty bucks
yeah oh my god I only spent 48 yeah so I
also spend 48 bucks yeah oh my so I was
looking at that one my two challenges
were get a female figure and get one
from a show that you watched recently
and I watched like a few episodes like
two months ago so yeah why didn't you
get the nesco figure I saw your I'm the
figure and I'm like [ __ ] fine
if I lose the Normie award and I knew
that team slaves of the most North
whatever the ranking said I'll have lost
the Normie award heart and
you know I want to risk it and also I
thought you know it's kind of a cool
figure yeah oh yeah yeah yeah it is if
we have nezarakku it makes you look like
fake anime fans get the [ __ ] out man
that's good that's good moto of lost
yeah hey I think GaN has like fulfilled
by prophecy